christophe da le score de la fédération
française de l'assurance était avec nous
ce matin dans son caddie bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous le réseau des
chambres de commerce et d'industrie de
france organise un tour de france de ses
risques
la martinique est concernée on va
d'abord voir avec vous on va d'abord
voir ce que vous qualifiez de risque et
christophe delcloy rare ici on peut
d'abord des risques naturels
ce qui est le plus simple puisque c'est
réglé par la loi par l'article du code
des assurances qui dit qu'un risque
naturel c'est un événement qui a une
ampleur exceptionnelle cyclone voit la
sicav ont essayé sur volcanique
exactement et après tout les autres
risques se sont lincendie le vol les
risques cyber que l'on connaît puis
qu'on couvre par tous les contrats
d'assurance
est ce que le risque épidémiologique
peut être considérée par exemple le
chikungunya ou la dengue qui peut
parfois frapper très fort et toucher des
pourcentages importants dans de salariés
dans une entreprise
nous ce qu'on a sur ce sont les dommages
aux biens on n'assure pas aller mais les
maladies de la branche de sciences
maladie après s'il y avait effectivement
un grand nombre de salariés qui sont qui
ne sont pas eux qui ne viennent pas
qu'ils ne peuvent pas se rendre au
travail et qui génère une perte
d'exploitation la has et aux chefs
d'entreprises de négocier alex en
assurant de la possibilité de mettre
éventuellement des frais supplémentaires
d'exploitation pourra les embaucher des
intérimaires est dans la même veine peux
t'assurer sur l'entreprise également
face aux risques par exemple d'une
dégradation sociale une grève longue
dure comme celle qu'on a connue en
martinique il y a dix ans 38 jours
non-stop de paralyser est là également
il ya deux choses oui vous pouvez s'il
ya des dommages à vos bâtiments il ya
une garantie qui s'appelle grèves
émeutes et mouvements populaires on peut
couvrir les dommages aux biens par
contre la perte d'exploitation qui s'est
ensuite un blanc cas d'un blocage là
effectivement il n'y a pas à ce jour de
couverture traditionnelle sur le pour
couvrir ce type de risque alors revenons
risque majeur puisque c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit
il ya eu pire ma il y à peu près d'ici
18 mois ce dernier phénomène d'ampleur
que nous avons connu dans la région
vous avez des chiffres les derniers
chiffres voyez irma c'est le
le phénomène le plus importantes du
régime des catastrophes naturelles et à
plus de 25 mille sinistrés pour un
montant qu'on a évalué à un milliard
neuf et on a décaissé aujourd'hui 1
milliard catois un peu moins de 80 % de
notre évaluation est ce que irma a été
vraiment un cas d'école c'est une sorte
de deux tourneurs de virages le secteur
de l'assurance alors malheureusement oui
il ya énormément d'enseignements qu'on a
qu'on a pu tirer de s'être de ce
phénomène climatique
martin sur le pré saint martin a
précisément du fait également de la de
la nature de deux des richesses sur
place qu'ils n'avaient rien à voir avec
saint barthélémy et on a pu notamment
pour les entreprises puisqu'il ya un
chiffre qu'il faut avoir en tête si en
nombre c'est à peine 10 % du nombre de
sinistres
en montant pour les entreprises 40% du
montant et notamment les hôtels en bord
de mer 48 hôtels sinistrés 10% du
montant total des dommages et là il ya
beaucoup d'enseignements sur la
prévention des risques et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'avec la ccit notre
partenaire nous avons mené ces trois
jours de colloque sur les risques
naturels et les risques des entreprises
ce qui s'est passé à saint martin avec
irma a permis de de changer de regard
qu'il faut y avoir sur l'assurance au
niveau national alors déjà les pouvoirs
publics se sont emparés du sujet nous on
milite pour une réforme des catastrophes
naturelles avec un certain nombre de
points qui permettraient d'améliorer le
sort des assurés suite à ce type
d'événement est effectivement on a est
la preuve
ma présence ici la mobilisation
notamment du comité des assureurs
antilles guyane pour faire passer les
bons messages savoir 1
à quels risques on est exposé deux
comment on peut s'en prémunir et 3 faire
un audit avec son assureur pour savoir
quelles sont les meilleures garanties
les assureurs vendent une promesse c'est
qu'en cas de sinistre tout se passe bien
il faut que cette promesse ne soient pas
déçus
oui il ya des inondations très
ponctuelle sur martin qui peut faire des
dégâts très très vite et des dizaines de
milliers d'euros qui partent dans les
flots du chômage technique une absence
de trésorerie pour pour vite redémarrer
si le moral n'est pas trop atteint c'est
important d'insister sur cette notion de
morale pas atteint et l'assurance
peut être une sorte de habad l'assurance
tout risque tout simplement
et vous avez raison sur tout maintenant
de plus en plus les contrats d'assurance
développe les assureurs développe des
modules de gestion de crise sert
d'accompagnement des assurés en cas de
traumatisme et c'est vous avez tout à
fait raison le moral est un point clé
est donc si les assureurs peuvent
accompagner gérer le retour à un bon
moral également par la garantie perte
d'exploitation il faut la souscrire ça
permet également de un retour une
reprise de l'activité le plus rapidement
possible sauf christophe belloc par
exemple sur la côte nord caraïbe très
exposées à la houle au aux dégâts de la
mer la montée des eaux
d'autres communes comme rivière pilote
dans le sud avec deux rivières qui passe
par le bourg certaines entreprises peut
être durement touché avec la bonté du
zoo et puis elle m'a tout simplement ces
sociétés ces entreprises sans temps de
dire qu'elles ne peuvent pas assurer
parce qu'elles sont dans des zones
malheureusement trop concerné par les
aléas alors malheureusement
effectivement nous un risque c'était
votre première question c'est le
croisement d'un aléa avec un enjeu
économique
l'aléa s'il y en a plus on ne peut plus
l'assurer mais face aux catastrophes
naturelles et un régime puisque c'est un
régime qui est totalement encadrée par
l'état qui permet en cas de refus par
lisa sion et du fait du motif des
catastrophes naturelles mais une
procédure qui existe qui le bureau
central de tarification qui peut être
saisie pour obtenir puisqu'il ya une
obligation d'assurer une obligation
d'assurance et d'assurer et donc à la
possibilité de monter un dossier
alors effectivement en fonction de la
lia y aura un coût important
il y aura des franchises qui seront
importantes donc c'est à l'assuré de de
faire son son calcul économique il ya un
deuxième point c'est qu'ils également
les plans de prévention des risques
naturels impose des mesures de
prescription que doivent respecter les
assurés est ce que les entreprises d les
sociétés connaissent ces procédures
comme l'idée d'écrire alors c'est alors
intermédiaires d'assurances agent
général courtier ou tout autre
intermédiaire qui doit connaître cet
assuré il suffit d'aller sur un site
internet un site internet pour monter un
dossier
vous aimez dire que la france a un des
régimes d'indemnisation les plus
performants au monde le plus cher aussi
le plus contraignant alors le plus cher
la prime moyenne en habitation ces 220
euros le coût de la surprime
catastrophes naturelles c'est 12% de
danse de 200 euros on est à vingt euros
par habitation en moyenne pour une
couverture contre tous les risques
naturels
il est universel c'est à dire que tous
les assurés ont l'obligation dès qu'ils
ont un contrat d'assurance dommage
d'avoir cette couverture et c'est grâce
justement à cette universalité à cette
mutualisation gobelins qu'on arrive à
avoir un coût très faible unitairement
parlons de de la garantie de perte
d'exploitation
on doit tous y pensent et pourquoi n'y
pense t-on pas assez selon vous par déjà
alors la perte d'exploitation ça permet
en cas d'un sinistre couvert de pouvoir
indemniser la continuité des charges
fixes et le résultat d'exploitation
c'est ce qu'on appelle à une façon
triviale à la sécurité sociale du chef
d'entreprise sans perte d'exploitation 8
cas sur 10 l'entreprise ne repart pas il
faut au moins y penser la demande à son
intermédiaire d'assurance pour qu'il
vous fasse une proposition de couverture
la perte d'exploitation
et si vous avez une catnat si vous avez
souscrit cette p o et bien vous serez
couvert en perte d'exploitation suite à
la catastrophe naturelle et pourquoi
comment expliquer que les chefs
d'entreprise n'y pense pas c'est parce
que ça coûte cher trop le nez dans le
guidon
c'est toutes ces raisons là
malheureusement est souvent un en france
et que on pense à l'assurance quand
c'est trop tard lorsqu'un sinistre
survient et c'est vrai dans tous les cas
et malheureusement en plus comme c'est
des garanties de garantie vous avez on
va s'assurer contre les incendies contre
le vol on pense pas forcément à
s'assurer en plus contre la part
d'exploitation en plus contre les
risques cyber et ses experts tout à
l'heure avant de rentrer dans ce studio
vous avez ce sourire propos de de la
cyber criminalité c'est quelque chose
qui y penche en flèche dans les chiffres
alors c'est tous les jours
l'exemple de tv5 monde a été un
révélateur également c'est vraiment un
risque explose en ce moment qui est tout
récent à ça fait trois quatre ans qu'on
s'y intéresse réellement sur marché
français de l'assurance et on est en
train de construire avec tous les
assureurs les meilleures réponses face à
ce type de risques et je tiens à
souligner également la l'état à une
agence qui s'appelle l' agence nationale
de sécurité des systèmes d'information
qui est vraiment à la pointe de sujet de
ce sujet lundi et qui nous aide beaucoup
pour développer ce type de couverture en
terme de comportement ce sera notre
dernière question il s'agit pas d'aller
dans un dans un cabinet d'assurances de
signer un document
il faut aussi s'intéresser à ce qu'on a
signés et est ce que tout le monde y
pense ça aussi non malheureusement c'est
comme toute signature comme tout acte
contractuel quand vous achetez un
terrain quand vous signez devant le
notaire vous vous intéressez à ce que
vous signez intéressez-vous à
l'assurance
merci d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
christophe deltombe on rappelle que vous
êtes de la fédération française de
l'assurance que vous êtes ici pour le
tour de france d'iris campanie de la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie merci
bonne journée
merci beaucoup
[Musique]